Bienvenue dans le MAKING-OF de "DESSINE-MOI UN ALIEN"
Je déclare "ouvert" le tournage de ce film
"DESSINE-MOI UN ALIEN" c'est un sketch sur un mec qui est obligé de donner un cours d'arts plastiques à des enfants.
Bien sûr ça se passe mal, ça se passe très mal.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il veut pas donner un cours et aussi parce que y'a un alien qui débarque
Qui dit "sketch un peu farfelu", dit Ludovic
Forcément je suis obligé de lui demander de réaliser le sketch.
Cyprien est venu me voir, il avait déjà écrit son scéna
Il m'a dit "ouais tu connais pas un réal bien pour faire ça"
J'fais: "Mec, il est en face de toi et en plus il est beau"
(rires)
Pourquoi vous rigolez ?
Il est super fort pour faire des situations hyper saugrenue. Il arrive à essayer de me faire jouer différemment, de créer un vrai personnage
C'est vrai que moi j'ai toujours des manières un peu de jouer les personnages et il a essayé de casser ça
et de trouver autre chose.
Ca démarre doucement, Cyp' il va faire le cours, en disant "qu'est-ce qui va se passer" et là bam! Un vaisseau. Bam! Un alien
Oh,c'est fou !
Il y a un enfant, une porte, et un concierge qui disparaissent. Je me suis dit, on trouve ça plus marrant si ils sont transformés en cacas verts.
Je fais Gaëtan, un gros branleur qui fait rien de sa vie et qui est forcé par sa mère à donner un cours de dessin
parce que il a pris des cours de dessin, sauf qu'il est jamais allé en cours.
C'est du thé que je fume
Faut que je ressemble à un rasta blanc et là on va faire un petit bouc mais juste le bas.
Il est bien dans ce personnage de mec
je trouve que le blond lui va très bien.
Et finalement, cette aventure va le faire collaborer avec des enfants et il va kiffer finalement le partage
Ça va toi
je t'avais pas vu. Ça va mec. YES
J'fais un peu daron et ils m'écoutent hein. Les enfants, rigolez .
Je suis bien content de tourner ça avec les enfants et ils sont vraiment adorables
ils sont tous un peu comédiens
Là, j'suis dans mon CREW. On est tous avec mes gars sûrs.
Voilà je les kiff de ouf et tout ,on a fait mille trucs ensemble.
On a brûlé des voitures
On a la petite Julianne par exemple qui a jouée dans pas mal de films, notamment dans le dernier film de Dany Boon.
Donc elle est vraiment adorable
Je voudrais par le dessin fait qu'il y a peu d'effets spéciaux
impressionnants d'aliens et jouer des enfants donc voilà j'ai dit ouais ça fait très projet hybride.
J'suis trop chaud, j'suis trop motivé par le projet et du coup et moi je me concentre
pas vraiment sur tout le visuel,Cyp' il est vraiment en tant que comédien sur le projet.
Il me fait confiance, donc c'est un peu notre bébé à 2.
Il y a un plan aux drones
tourné juste au dessus de l'école comme ça qui va suivre des enfants qui courent.
Un plan qui est très chère à Ludovik parce que les que ça s'inspire un peu de shining.
Désormais, il sera content de m'appeler Shiningdovick ou Lubrik
Il y a une astuce très très intéressante, c'est que cette porte n'est pas du tout une porte extérieure
Alors là il n'y a pas de neige et dehors il y a de la neige.
Il y a aussi du fond vert pour ajouter l'extérieur.
Comment faire naître la peur là dedans.
Bah on voit déjà tu filmes un alien flippant
Tu crées des cadres, des contre-plongées, les arrivées très lentes des contre-jours hyper menaçants.
On n'arrive pas trop à savoir ce que c'est.
Et ensuite un autre ingrédient super important pour faire la peur c'est que tu filmes des gens qui ont peur.
Alors donc on est un peu dans une ambiance un peu "éssai" parce que sont les un peu dans des lumières un peu surréaliste
Bah,je rigole
C'est énorme, Cyprien vient filmer ,regarde, c'est énorme, mec.
On pense que l'alien est ultra activé,mais alors pas du tout en fait.
En gros, c'est une grosse marionnette
Il y a eu plusieurs étapes pour la construction.
Une partie qui a été faite par des costumiers donc on avait le costume qui était réalisé en annexe.
On a réalisé la construction du corps à l'intérieur de l'alien.
On incorporé un mécanisme avec des servomoteurs
Et Damien à l'intérieur, le comédien pouvait contrôler le cou et une partie, voilà des mouvements de l'alien.
Il y avait plein de petites manettes. Pour pencher la tête l'aller qui tire une tige.
Il ne sait pas où il va exactement donc on lui a mis des traces au sol et du coup avec ses genoux, il voyait vraiment plus où il devait y aller.
On peut dire l'alien, c'est vraiment petite industrie à lui tout seul,quoi.
Et concernant le pistolet, on a fait la réalisation sur un logiciel de 3D et il a été imprimé ensuite en 3D.
T'as dit quoi là parce que je suis en train de régler le plan.
On a eu une super équipe pour créer les effets spéciaux, c'était super important.
Notamment pour le vaisseau spatial, l'œil de l'alien, la disparition de la porte, du gardien et de la petite Léa.
Alors je vais prendre en photo...
Ludovic en 360 ° pour pouvoir venir le scanner en 3D et l'utiliser pour les effets où il se fait aspirer en 3D.
Ils vont faire un effet spécial aux petits oignons.
Parce que les effets spéciaux on se rabat sur le projet
Dès que tout ça sera remplacé en
On pourra retirer ce faux œil en vert là par un vrai œil avec des réflexions de la salle.
Et ça défonce hein,  les effets sont super réalistes, le rendu, il est vraiment flippant.
Enfin ça fonctionne carrément on est super content.
L'idée heu ,voilà c'était un peu concurrencer spielberg Maintenant on arrive dans le game tout le monde a peur
On est en train d'organiser la petite avant-première pour quelques privilégiés
Petite avant-première mais c'est aussi dans les nouveaux, nouveaux studios.
Donc on est, c'est là où on tourne avec SQUEEZIE, toutes les vidéos GAMING.
Donc on va regarder le nouveau court-métrage QLED de SAMSUNG qui est partenaire.
J'espère que ça va plaire aux gens ça va envoyer du lourd
C'est ce que j'espère
OK, les gars, OK,  OK
On a un énorme problème, il y a un énorme
En fait vous voyez les rushs du tournage, je vais vous expliquer. Je me suis fait un jus d'orange et ...
J'ai fait tomber le jus d'orange dessus et il est tombé dans les toilettes, et j'ai chier dessus.
Non c'était une blague parce que c'est une fin de tournage.
(CRIS DE JOIE)
La rencontre entre l'alien et Gaëtan
Danse de fin de tournage
BRAVO A VOUS LES GARS
ABONNEZ-VOUS
Sous-titres : OKIÑO + Jakomo32
(abonnez-vous à ma chaîne)